Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Mia nonna faceva
dei cannelloni spettacolari.
E non solo perché erano buoni,
come forse potete vedere
da questa mia immagine alle spalle,
che velatamente mostra
con quanto gusto potevo mangiarli;
ma perché questi cannelloni
lei li faceva a mano,
e li faceva tutti uguali.
E io ero affascinato da questi cannelloni,
allineati uno accanto all'altro,
in una teglia, tutti esattamente
delle stesse dimensioni.
Tanto che se, per caso,
nel portare una porzione nel mio piatto,
un pezzo se ne staccava
e rimaneva nella teglia,
io provavo un forte senso di disappunto
per quella parte mancante
del cannellone nel mio piatto.
La cosa strana è che, crescendo,
alcune di queste sensazioni
io continuo a provarle.
Per esempio, a me piace
riparare orologi meccanici.
Un orologio è formato
da una serie di ingranaggi,
che interagiscono tra di loro
per ottenere il movimento delle lancette
in un preciso arco temporale.
Se uno di questi ingranaggi si rompe,
l'orologio si ferma.
Se io sostituisco quell'ingranaggio
con un altro ingranaggio identico,
e non faccio errori,
l'orologio riprende
la sua funzionalità al 100%.
Posso ripetere questa
operazione tante volte,
e ogni volta otterrò
la ripresa dell'orologio al 100%.
Se io mettessi, riportassi su un grafico,
quello che vi ho appena detto,
vedrei un istogramma
come quello alle mie spalle:
tutte le barre al 100%,
ogni volta che riparo l'orologio.
Sembrano i cannelloni di mia nonna,
tutti allineati nella teglia:
è uno spettacolo guardarli.
È un po' come compiere
la stessa operazione:
due più due farà quattro,
ogni volta che sommerete
questi due numeri tra di loro.
Però io sono un medico,
sono un oncologo, mi occupo di ricerca.
E in questo campo,
due più due non fa mai quattro.
Due più due fa più o meno quattro,
con un certo margine di errore.
E agli istogrammi manca sempre un pezzo.
E questo mi crea disappunto,
come la parte mancante
del cannellone nel mio piatto;
ma anche la curiosità di sapere perché.
Ora non vi preoccupate,
vi faccio un esempio
e cerco di spiegarmi meglio.
Se io considero un gruppo di pazienti
con un tumore al polmone,
uno specifico tumore al polmone,
si chiama "tumore non a piccole cellule" -
l'acronimo è quello
che vedete alle mie spalle -
e di questi pazienti prendo un sottogruppo
in cui il tumore al polmone
produce una proteina, che si chiama Pdl1 -
anche qui, è una proteina
che fa una cosa semplice, purtroppo.
Dice al sistema immunitario del paziente:
"Non attaccare il tumore,
lascialo crescere!"
Per fortuna, abbiamo una terapia
che è in grado di bloccare
questa proteina,
così che il sistema
immunitario del paziente
può aggredire il tumore e distruggerlo.
È un sistema perfetto:
stesso tipo di tumore;
stesso tipo di proteina;
una terapia specifica.
Ci aspetteremmo che il 100% dei pazienti
risponda positivamente alla terapia.
E invece?
Invece no, risponde meno del 50%.
E allora la mia domanda è:
perché non il 100%?
Che cosa c'è, in quella parte
mancante dell'istogramma?
Per poter dare una risposta forse banale,
ma che è il modo
più semplice per spiegarvelo,
né il tumore né il paziente
sono orologi meccanici.
Noi non conosciamo tutti gli ingranaggi
che sono responsabili
del funzionamento del corpo umano,
compreso il sistema immunitario,
o che sono responsabili dello sviluppo
e della progressione di un tumore.
Quindi, può essere
che quello che io sto considerando
come un unico tipo di tumore,
negli stessi pazienti,
non lo sia.
E che in uno specifico paziente,
quel tumore che io considero
"non a piccole cellule Pdl1 positivo"
produca altri fattori
che limitano la capacità
del sistema immunitario di attaccarlo,
o che lo rendono
più resistente alla terapia.
Ma può essere che i pazienti
non siano tutti uguali,
che siano più o meno
geneticamente predeterminati
ad attivare il sistema immunitario
contro un tumore.
Stili di vita, fattori sociali,
fattori ambientali possono impattare.
Sempre di più,
la medicina si sta spostando
in un ambito in cui la cura
è rivolta allo specifico paziente
per la specifica patologia
di quel paziente.
Si chiama "medicina di precisione".
Quindi, in altre parole,
non basta più raccogliere informazioni
da quelli che sono
i principali quattro pilastri
sui quali un medico basa
la propria capacità
di diagnosi, prognosi,
prescrizione terapeutica,
e cioè la visita del paziente,
le immagini di radiologia,
gli esami di laboratorio
o gli esami istopatologici.
Abbiamo bisogno di altre informazioni.
Anche qui, una buona notizia:
abbiamo la tecnologia per farlo,
e lo stiamo facendo.
Possiamo raccogliere informazioni
molto dettagliate
su ogni specifico tumore,
sulla genomica del paziente,
sugli stili di vita del paziente.
Tutti dati, questi,
che stiamo già raccogliendo.
Pensate che l'incremento annuo
dei dati digitali, in sanità, è del 36%!
Molto più di qualsiasi ambito
della nostra attività,
come quella industriale,
o nell'intrattenimento,
o nei servizi finanziari.
36% di incremento ogni anno:
una marea di dati!
E allora, possiamo utilizzare questi dati
per far sì che due più due,
anche in ambito oncologico, in medicina,
faccia quattro, o più o meno
si avvicini a quattro.
Il problema è: come facciamo
ad analizzare tutti questi dati?
Abbiamo bisogno di tecnologia,
e questa tecnologia è data
dall'intelligenza artificiale.
Processi come il deep learning,
e i neural network,
sono in grado di identificare,
tra centinaia di parametri,
quei parametri che mi
consentono di prevedere
se un determinato paziente,
con una specifica malattia,
risponderà a una determinata terapia.
Quale sarà l'evoluzione del tumore,
in quello specifico paziente,
per quello specifico tumore,
mi aiuterà a capire
quante varianti di un tumore,
che io considero tutte uguali, esistono.
Potrò usare quei dati
per sviluppare nuove soluzioni
in ambito di ricerca biomedica.
Ma allora, la domanda che io mi pongo è:
se ho i dati, e so come analizzarli,
ma perché, oggi, noi in ospedale
non abbiamo soluzioni
di intelligenza artificiale
che praticamente aiutino i medici
nella loro professione?
Ci sono varie ragioni,
perché questo accade.
Ragioni che sono legate a:
gestione dei dati,
e della privacy dei pazienti;
sicurezza di questi dati;
come questi dati sono stati immagazzinati
negli anni precedenti,
prima che si immaginasse
l'intelligenza artificiale;
costi; riorganizzazione di ospedali.
Ma c'è un aspetto,
che io ritengo fondamentale,
che è a monte di tutto questo:
la generazione delle soluzioni.
In questo momento, ci sono due mondi
che non si stanno parlando
sufficientemente tra di loro.
Da un lato, abbiamo
scienziati e ricercatori
che nell'ambito
dell'intelligenza artificiale
hanno fatto cose incredibili.
Siamo in grado di simulare
voli aerospaziali;
abbiamo macchine che si guidano da sole;
siamo in grado di analizzare
miliardi di dati sul web
per rispondere a domande,
influenzare le scelte dei cittadini,
decidere se migliorare un processo e come.
Questi ricercatori hanno già sviluppato
alcune soluzioni in ambito sanitario,
ma pochissime di queste
sono praticamente utilizzabili.
E uno dei motivi è che spesso utilizzano
dati simulati, e non dati reali.
Dall'altra parte,
c'è il mondo dei ricercatori
in ambito biomedico, dei medici,
che conoscono il significato
di un dato noto
in un contesto di ingranaggi
di cui non sappiamo neanche l'esistenza.
È la quotidianità di un medico,
definire quei parametri noti,
che significato hanno,
consapevole che ce ne sono una serie
di cui non conosciamo l'esistenza.
Bene, questi due mondi si devono parlare;
e se questi due mondi si parlano,
le soluzioni arrivano.
E la storia che vi voglio
raccontare adesso lo dimostra.
La storia si è svolta
all'ospedale San Raffaele, dove lavoro.
Voi ricorderete tutti che,
soprattutto durante il primo anno
della pandemia da CoVid,
da noi avevamo i Pronto Soccorsi
saturi di pazienti
con sintomi riconducibili a CoVid.
La gran parte di questi
venivano ricoverati:
non eravamo in grado,
e non avevamo le conoscenze,
per stabilire quali di questi pazienti
avrebbe sviluppato una forma lieve
o una forma grave di malattia.
Lo scoprivamo dopo, alla fine
del decorso della malattia.
Questo significava saturare
posti in ospedale;
e quindi, con il mio amico
e collega Antonio Esposito,
desiderosi di mettersi a disposizione
per cercare di aiutare
a risolvere quella situazione,
ci siamo posti una domanda:
possiamo trovare un sistema
che in brevissimo tempo,
dall'entrata del paziente
al Pronto Soccorso,
sia in grado di prevedere
se quel paziente svilupperà o no
una forma grave di CoVid,
e se sviluppa una forma lieve
possiamo mandarlo a casa,
magari con un monitoraggio costante?
Per farlo, ci siamo messi a studiare
la letteratura internazionale
fino a quel momento generata.
Centinaia di parametri,
ognuno dei quali, singolarmente,
si associava a una forma grave
o una forma lieve di malattia.
Mancavano totalmente studi
che erano in grado di integrare
tutti questi parametri
per dare una risposta univoca.
Questo paziente avrà
una forma lieve, o una forma grave?
Per farlo, per rispondere
a questa domanda,
avevamo bisogno
di intelligenza artificiale.
E allora?
E allora ci siamo rivolti
a quegli scienziati, e a quei ricercatori,
che hanno fatto cose incredibili
nell'ambito dell'intelligenza artificiale.
E ci siamo rivolti a Microsoft.
E Microsoft, con due aziende partner,
ascoltando le nostre competenze
nella definizione
della significatività dei dati,
insieme a noi, in breve tempo
ha sviluppato una piattaforma
che in 30 minuti dall'arrivo
del paziente in Pronto Soccorso
era in grado di stabilire
se quel paziente avrebbe sviluppato
una forma lieve, media
o grave di patologia.
E di inviare al medico,
su un app dedicata, il messaggio.
Tra centinaia di parametri,
questo sistema era in grado
di definirne cinque:
età, sesso e saturazione di ossigeno,
facilmente rilevabili
all'ingresso del paziente;
due parametri venivano identificati
dalle immagini della TAC toracea
di questi pazienti -
badate bene, senza l'aiuto del radiologo.
Sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
estraevano i dati dalla TAC,
e li inviavano alla piattaforma:
30 minuti, e avevamo la risposta.
Se avessimo utilizzato
questa piattaforma a livello nazionale,
avremmo ridotto del 27%
le ospedalizzazioni.
Ora lo so che cosa vi state chiedendo:
perché non lo avete fatto?
Non l'abbiamo fatto
perché, per generare la piattaforma,
abbiamo utilizzato dati di 1500 pazienti
di 15 ospedali del Nord Italia
durante la prima ondata della pandemia.
Ma quando hai una soluzione del genere,
devi dimostrare che funziona:
si chiama "validazione".
E l'abbiamo validata
sui pazienti della seconda ondata.
Quando abbiamo dimostrato
che la soluzione funzionava -
e badate bene, ha funzionato
nel 100 percento dei pazienti -
per fortuna sono arrivati i vaccini,
che ci hanno tolto le castagne dal fuoco.
E quindi, le ospedalizzazioni
si sono ridotte,
e noi ci siamo fermati.
Ma abbiamo imparato una cosa,
una cosa molto importante:
che mettendo insieme le competenze
di scienziati di diverse
estrazioni culturali,
potevamo sviluppare soluzioni
praticamente applicabili
all'interno di un contesto dell'ospedale.
Ed è quello che stiamo facendo.
All'ospedale San Raffaele,
stiamo costruendo una piattaforma
che è in grado di utilizzare
l'intelligenza artificiale
per recuperare i dati,
all'interno delle
banche dati dell'ospedale,
e di utilizzare questi dati
per rispondere a domande
come quelle che vi ho mostrato prima.
Per fare questa piattaforma,
abbiamo creato una serie
di "casi di studio".
Uno era il tumore non a piccole cellule
del polmone, e Pdl1 positivo,
di cui vi ho parlato prima.
E la domanda che ci siamo posti è:
possiamo prevedere, prima di dare
la terapia a questi pazienti,
quali pazienti non risponderanno
a quella terapia?
Perché normalmente, questo lo scopriamo
quando è troppo tardi.
Se lo riesco a scoprire prima,
posso proporre una terapia alternativa,
o sviluppare una terapia alternativa.
Be', siamo in fase avanzata di studio,
e i dati sono molto promettenti.
Io sono sicuro che riusciremo
in questo compito.
E se riusciremo, come riusciremo,
là il livello di istogramma mancante
da questi grafici sarà molto ridotto.
E almeno in questo campo,
due più due farà più quattro
di quanto abbia fatto fino ad adesso.
La sicurezza che riusciremo
mi viene anche dal fatto
che, mentre mi formavo alla scuola
dei cannelloni di mia nonna,
recepivo un messaggio di un film magico,
il primo film che ho visto al cinema
di cui ho memoria, ormai sessant'anni fa.
E questo messaggio
diceva una cosa semplice:
"Tutto è possibile, anche l'impossibile."
Grazie.
(Applausi)